siamo sempre stati abituati a lieto fine
sempre fin da piccoli se ci pensi ogni
favola ogni fiaba ogni storia ogni
canzone che parla d'amore sempre finisce
con qualcosa che trionfa ma la realtà
della storia è proprio sempre questa
purtroppo non passa giorno in cui non
sentiamo la notizia in merito
all'innalzamento delle temperature del
polo nord
all'ennesima specie in via di estinzione
all aumento delle tonnellate dei kg di
plastica che si riversano all'interno
dei nostri mari
o ancora all'irreversibile sbiancamento
della barriera corallina
forse signori ci stiamo dimenticando
veramente di un piccolo dettaglio
ovvero che l'ambiente crea la persona
l'ambiente non è solo qualcosa che da
sfondo alla tua vita ma è qualcosa che
permette la vita stessa e quindi in un
certo senso la qualità della tua vita è
strettamente connessa alla qualità
dell'ambiente
viviamo in una società incredibile dal
momento che tutto l'intero futuro
dell'umanità passa attraverso le nostre
mani e questo può essere affascinante ma
come anche terribile dal momento che il
nostro futuro dipenderà solo ed
esclusivamente da ciò che facciamo oggi
in questo preciso istante e di tutto ciò
mi viene di pormi automaticamente tre
domande
la prima e abbiamo le conoscenze e le
risorse per affrontare questa situazione
sì tuttavia arriva la seconda domanda
ovvero abbiamo la formazione e la
consapevolezza per affrontare questa
situazione
no perlomeno non tutti e non sempre è
quindi arriva in cina la terza domanda
che la più profonda
ovvero ci sentiamo di meritare un mondo
migliore
io sì e tu anche io ma forse proprio
questa dovrebbe essere la nostra domanda
di partenza perché se non crediamo di
meritarci un mondo migliore
non agiremo per realizzarlo fino ad oggi
l'umanità agito considerandosi al di
sopra della natura difatti anche lo
storico harari nel suo libro a breve
storia dell'umanità afferma in un
passaggio che in soli 70 mila
anni la nostra specie ha portato nel
mondo i danni che c'erano durante l'era
glaciale e che nell'arco di un secolo
potremmo causare i danni che ci sono
stati dall'asteroide che ha portato
all'estinzione dinosauri quindi non
sembra proprio molto positivo
difatti ribadisco l'umanità fino ad oggi
ha agito considerandosi al di sopra
della natura ma noi in realtà dipendiamo
da essa c'è la nostra salute e il nostro
benessere
la nostra vita stessa dipende dalla
salute della natura consapevoli di ciò
abbiamo detto facciamo qualcosa di
positivo per l'ambiente
facciamo qualcosa di concreto che
coinvolga tutti più persone possibili
quindi ci siamo detti scendiamo in
piazza e raccogliamo il maggior numero
di rifiuti che incrociamo ciò che più
popola le strade del nostro centro della
nostra città sono i mozziconi di
sigaretta
all'inizio ci siamo detti ma perché
musiche di sigaretta poi facendo un po
di ricerca abbiamo scoperto che sembrano
piccoli insignificanti ma in realtà
inquinano tantissimo
pensate contengono oltre 4.000 sostanze
tossiche nocive e cancerogene come ad
esempio la nicotina la naftalina
l'ammoniaca io non sono uno scienziato
però soltanto questi termini mi fanno
preoccupare sembrano e sono
effettivamente dannosi difatti se
prendiamo un mozzicone di sigaretta e lo
immergiamo in un litro d acqua
questa rilascerà abbastanza sostanze
cancerogene da uccidere tutti i pesci
presenti in quell'acqua ed a minare così
il sistema vivente acquatico
inoltre le sostanze nocive presenti nei
mozziconi di sigaretta sono stati
trovati nel 70 per cento degli uccelli
marini e nel 30 per cento delle
tartarughe marine trovate morte
pensate che vengono abbandonate nel
nostro pianeta oltre 4.500 milioni
harvey di mozziconi di sigaretta inoltre
una sigaretta in fase di combustione
rilascia più polveri sottili di un
diesel euro 4 ed i fatti queste polveri
sottili entrano all'interno del nostro
apparato respiratorio causando malattie
gravi tra cui anche la sma poi riescono
a penetrare all'interno degli alveoli
polmonari e causare anche problemi
all'apparato circolatorio oltre che alla
parata rispetto respiratorio e qui
potrei andare ancora avanti no direi che
abbiamo capito tutti e che possiamo
andare avanti
ok ok allora vi raccontiamo com'è nata
la nostra iniziativa
stavo per metterci all'opera ma poi
abbiamo scoperto che ci servivano i
permessi da parte del comune ma come
direte voi anche per accogliere dei
mozziconi di sigaretta servono i
fermenti del comune
ebbene sì perché noi volevamo fare
un'iniziativa che fosse talmente grande
da coinvolgere tutti quanti
altro che ripuliamo udine ripuliamo
l'universo esattamente arrivato in
comune ci dicono che ci serviva un
appoggio da parte di un ente come
un'associazione è che ci si arriva anche
una copertura assicurativa bene una
volta saputo ciò che amiamo subito
gigliola che ci concede tutto ed eravamo
praticamente pronti ma secondo voi era
sufficiente tutto ciò
no perché per fare la cosa veramente
bene come volevamo farla noi ci
servivano gli appoggi da parte degli
enti giusti come ad esempio la net
quindi abbiamo instaurato anche una
collaborazione con la net e così una
volta al mese con costanza ci siamo
ritrovati a raccogliere mozziconi di
sigaretta in un anno e mezzo di attività
siamo riusciti a contagiare più di 80
nominativi di volontari a collaborare
con enti pubblici come l'università
degli studi di udine e sei enti privati
a essere pubblicati o aver avuto più di
trenta articoli mediatici in base a
questa attività è anche un
riconoscimento dal punto di vista della
regione friuli venezia giulia in
occasione dell'evento direzione alla
sostenibilità tutti questi risultati ci
hanno fatto comprendere l'importanza di
due
la loro riti ci hanno insegnato ovvero
l'amore è l'esempio l'amore perché
questa iniziativa si svolge totalmente
sulla base dell'amore perché nasce
esclusivamente per fare del bene
in un certo senso amare l'ambiente è un
modo profondo per amare se stessi e
secondo l'esempio parla esempio il
miglior maestro nell'esempio ti fa
vedere come si fanno le cose non
semplicemente tele spiega l'unione di
queste due caratteristiche che
accomunano di questa iniziativa è
l'esperienza che è un valore incredibile
dal momento che è in trance terribile ed
è tua per sempre
e proprio questa unione di
caratteristiche ha generato un
iniziativa di valore considerate da
tutti i lati detti prima considerate che
abbiamo raccolto 170mila mozziconi di
sigaretta quindi aiutateci a continuare
la nostra iniziativa aiutateci a
continuare il nostro cammino
magari aiutateci a trovare un ente una
startup un'azienda che possa prendere
questi mozziconi che noi raccogliamo e
dare vita e dare nuova vita loro in modo
ecologico in modo sostenibile
bene ora ci conoscete contiamo su di voi
grazie grazie